[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كورتني ميلر هي أم لطفلين
ومستشارة في الرضاعة من كاري نورث
كارولينا إن وظيفتها هي مساعدة الوالدين على
الرضاعة ولكن حتى بالنسبة للمحترفين فإن
هذا أصعب مما يبدو  كنت مثل ،
أنا أم ممرضة أطفال ، لقد حصلت على هذا
كما لو علمت الأمهات كيفية الرضاعة الطبيعية
بالتأكيد سأكون بخير ، أدركت
أنني كنت أعرف فقط مثل أول يومين إلى ثلاثة
أيام ثم من  ثم أعني أن
الأمور تتغير ، نعم ،
عالمة الأحياء ليلا ستريكلاند تعرف كيف
تشعر في عام 2009 ، لقد كافحت من أجل إنتاج
ما يكفي من حليب الثدي لطفلها واضطرت
إلى الاعتماد على تركيبة
ستريكلاند وتساءلت عما إذا كان بإمكانها إنشاء
بديل في المختبر
يشبه إلى حد كبير  حليب الأم
ماذا يعني هذا للأمهات
والآباء والأطفال
إذا كان بإمكانك إنتاج حليب بشري
خارج الجسم بعد أكثر من 10 سنوات بعد ذلك ،
تقترب ستريكلاند من اكتشاف أنها
شاركت في تأسيس الحليب الحيوي لتطوير تقنية زراعة الخلايا ،
إنه نفس النوع من الاستخدام العملي  د
لصنع اللحوم المزروعة في المختبر ، لكن الحليب الحيوي يزرع
اللبن البشري الذي يصنع الخلايا نحن
نجمع الخلايا من مصدرين مختلفين
، الحليب ومن الأنسجة
التي يحتوي عليها الحليب الذي يحتوي على العديد من
الدهون والبروتينات المفيدة التي
تحصل عليها عادةً فقط من ستريكلاند الثدي.
إنها الخطوة الأولى نحو
حل محتمل للآباء والأمهات الذين لا يستطيعون
إرضاع أطفالهم أو الحصول على
الحليب المتبرع به ،
لكن الحليب الحيوي لا يزال بعيدًا عن
بيع منتج لمدة ثلاث سنوات على الأقل ،
يقول ستريكلاند إن
أول حليب حيوي يحتاج إلى نمو
خلايا الثدي بشكل أكبر بكثير  الحجم بتكلفة أقل
وإقناع المنظمين بأن
المنتج آمن للبشر الأكثر ضعفًا ،
تقول
ستريكلاند إنه حتى لو وصل الحليب الحيوي إلى هذا الحد ،
فلن يكون المنتج تمامًا كما
يقول خبراء حليب الأم ، لا
يتم إنتاج جميع مكونات حليب الأم
بواسطة  الخلايا التي يتم استزراعها في
هذه المفاعلات الحيوية ،
معظم الأحماض الدهنية ، والدهون التي
تساعد على نمو الدماغ ، تأتي
من دم الأم
ولكنها تؤمن ستريكلاند  يمكن أن يساعد عمل eves bio milk
أيضًا في زيادة
فهمنا لحليب الأم ويمكن أن يؤدي ذلك إلى
اختراقات علمية جديدة.
مشاريع الطاقة التي
تأمل أن يكون منتج biomilk أكثر
استدامة من
مطحنة الحليب أيضًا ، فهي تتبرع ببضع أونصات
من حليبها لأبحاث الحليب الحيوي ،
وقد يراه البعض كبديل
لحليب الأم ولا أراه بهذه الطريقة.
مجرد خيار آخر
لك